hey everybody its Jesse happy Monday
hope everybody had a nice weekend I've
gotten a decent amount done on the site
since the last time we had a stream you
could see in my Trello board I've got
some more things in the done section and
today we're going to work on this one
hiding and showing some content on the
teams page so let's go to the code let
me show you what the problem is if you
want to look at all the things that have
been done since the last stream check
out the github repo and look at the
commit history there will be dates on
everything so you'll be able to see step
by step what changed in the code I also
have a link to this demo site so you can
check out the rest of the site you can
see I've put in we had a little vote for
the font on Friday if you remember I
really like the sins oh I tried both of
them and this one just looked look
really nice you can see it even on the
home page so that turned out really nice
so thanks to everybody who added their
opinion about that you can see I even
added it here and this section just
super nice so I think we're going to go
with that now let's check out the the
team page hey guys I'm just looking at
the chat I'm doing good I was everybody
going yeah so I think the last time we
looked through the team's page we didn't
really have much more on here so since
then I've actually added some some data
for these cards and you can see I've
added all the sections with just kind of
some basic things for the cards I still
have you know these kind of test
sections down here
I've also added this like tiny hero ish
section here so there were a lot of
images on the home page for the original
site that every time you refresh the
page the image would change and that was
kind of acting as their hero images for
the home page so after with a meeting
Friday morning and I found out that the
the people who were the head of this
department of making the site for really
liked those images and spent a lot of
time picking them out so I decided to
add them in and each interior page you
have a tutorial about building it yet
for the snazzy act axiom tech computer
maintenance service and repair asked if
we have a tutorial about building it uh
building what specifically there's a
catch kind of a delay here so I'm not
sure what I was talking about when you
when you post to that so let me know
what what do you want to know the
tutorial bot I might have gone over it
in a previous video and if not maybe I
could make a recorded video about it so
I'm going to try to add these in I think
it's better anyway because the odds of
someone coming to the site enough times
and getting to see every image was
really low a website with the one you're
shy
okay so someone asked about a tutorial
so I've been doing live streams pretty
much every weekday showing how I'm
building this site so I have some live
streams on this channel on free code
camps channel and I have some on my my
own channel that I had done previously
so between the two channels you'll see a
lot of what went into this site I didn't
start from scratch for this one so you
know you won't be able to start you know
from very basics at some point I'd like
to do one just totally from scratch set
everything up but for now for this
project there's a really tight deadline
in fact today is the day that I had said
I would like to have it
to the point where we could really begin
testing it in different browsers and
things so that means I want to have at
least demo content in for every
different page that we'll have and you
know the different elements on the pages
so I still have some work to do today
but I think it's it's still doable that
I can have all that all that done I have
some people working on doing some some
image editing and getting me some images
for the section so that I don't have yet
and I have someone else working on the
content you see there's a whole lot of
text here so we're probably not going to
keep this much text I have somebody
who's setting up servers right now so
I'll have some help so I can just focus
just on developing this site see it does
peak spin all right so that's like you
speak Spanish just a tiny bit of Spanish
I haven't uh I had some Spanish courses
in high school and in college but it's
been a long time since I spoke in
Spanish so I haven't kept up with it all
right so let me look let me show you
briefly the old side I think we went
over this section in a previous video
but I want to show you again kind of the
issue that we had so this is the team
page on the old sites you can see the
similarities
we just we added this content here so
the stuff that was in this red box is
not here like I said it's probably going
to get cut down a little bit because
that's that's a whole lot of text to
start out with and then these sections
where you have these cards basically I'm
going to take this info and have them in
these sections but there's a lot here
you see we have this accordion kind of
thing and there's a lot and we had some
problems like when the accordion opens
it just puts you right in the middle of
the list so not really ideal it's not
what people expect when they open that
they would expect to be at the top of
the list you see there's a lot so I'm
thinking I don't really want to have all
that stuff on the page it would be crazy
to scroll through that especially on
mobile so
the plan is I'm going to have these
sections so it doesn't seem that bad
right now but after we get all the data
in it's going to be a lot a lot of stuff
are you guys having trouble hearing me
am I did somebody said asking what I'm
saying let me know if you're having
trouble hearing they all um I'll try to
adjust them maybe you talk louder and
adjust some of my settings I actually
have a trick when I'm live-streaming
to help me talk louder than normal I
play music in my headphones because we
all know when when you listen to music
and your headphones you tend to talk
louder okay awesome
awesome so it seems like everybody's
hearing me all right
hey so so if you have a problem with
talking low like I do sometimes or maybe
mumbling a bit and you're going to do a
YouTube video try out that trick as long
as the music's not too distracting at
least it's been working for me alright
so these cards I think we started these
cars just really briefly to kind of go
over what's going on here the problem
with the cards was that as we were kind
of resizing things these cards were
growing and shrinking but the image
wasn't so we had this white space
underneath it didn't look good so the
solution to that ended up being so much
easier than I thought it would be all I
did was I set a max height for this card
so the images are all going to be square
and they're all going to be a hundred
pixels by 100 pixels square okay I have
a lot of different size images some of
them are really small so the only way
I'm going to be able to get these
uniform is just to make them 100 by 100
square and that way even the smallest
pictures should work and since I'm
setting my max height to be a hundred
pixels then why should never have a
problem with that white space coming in
on the bottom the only issue that I have
right now is the space gets a little bit
tight so you can see when we shrink it
there's a
a tiny window right now where there's
just not enough padding on the bottom if
one of these rows goes onto two lines I
don't know how many people have a long
enough title that that will happen for
but if I can avoid it I'd like to I
don't want to spend too much time
messing with it since it's such a small
screen it's just a really a few pixels
where that happens in terms of width but
if I can't fix that I think and maybe I
can just drop the padding down all the
way around and that will just make just
enough space to get that on the next
line but I'm not going to worry about it
until I get more data in there because
it could be that you know somebody else
hasn't even longer title and it doesn't
work even with the padding adjustment
and so I have to think of something else
so I'm not going to duplicate all that
work but for now it works
I've used this red is the same color red
we're using in the background and the
idea is when you click on one of these a
modal is going to pop up and it's going
to have all that other information that
we see in here because for some people
it's a lot some people not so much but
no matter what even if it was a sentence
it's still not going to fit in these
cards and and work the way we wanted to
so today we're just going to try to hide
these sections so what I would like to
happen is that if you click on the sit
is title it would show everything so by
default the only section that would show
would be this first one and then you
just see the titles for the other ones
I'd like to put in a small icon here to
show give some indication that this
thing is clickable so a lot of times on
menus you see like you know the little
arrow icon and then when you click it to
be open the icon is going down it's
pointing down and when it's closed it's
pointing to the right so I'm going to
try to put that in so let me show you
where I go usually for icons I think I
may have done this in a previous video
but it's been a while so show
again so I like to go to Google of
material design icons there we go so
this is the site where you can get
material design icons let's see sitting
in Ferrara Chevron there we go okay so
it's called a chevron we have the
chevron right but where's my chevron
done we may just have to manually rotate
it then I really thought that I had used
a down Chevron at some point but oh whoa
so we'll click on this one and you can
see the little cross would be nice and
icon actually that's a good idea okay so
in the live stream we had a good idea to
use a little cross as an icon so it
would be like like a plus you would
click it just saying like hey there's
more here and then I'm assuming we would
that plus would turn into a minus and
then you click the minus and then that
would I actually like that better I like
that a lot better
let's try that so I've used this on
previous sites but I'm going to try that
plus and minus plus if we can find it no
let's see no how about this what we can
do this will be tricky we can use the
close and then just spin it slightly
with CSS type cross all right that's a B
I tried to type cross nothing came up
but maybe I just needed to scroll up
maybe less to four done all right no not
seeing cross here I'm sure they have it
maybe in a different font icon set but
this should work just to spin this so
let's grab this and I like to grab the
the SVG version so we'll load this will
download this let's see
we just throw this and downloads for now
I already have it okay since I already
have it let's just replace it because I
don't want to search for it
and what I want it right here so I can
open it so you can see we have this tiny
little cross if we go into view source
it's just such a small amount of markup
right here we can just take that markup
and copy it and put it right into our
code and it will show up so let's just
throw it in there now and see how it
looks it will definitely need some
adjustment but for now we just want
something in there and I'm not going to
worry about adjusting it too much right
now which I'd like to get to you know
actually showing and hiding something
and if you haven't joined me before I
only last room for half an hour should
add oh okay somebody just told me it's
add is the is the keyword that we want
to search for all right let me let me
just make a note that it's actually add
and I'll do that later so okay we got
greetings from Italy all right awesome
I've got a some great grandparents that
came from Italy so awesome which editor
is that I'm using Adam and and then okay
remove is the keyword for a - okay
awesome thank you for that I can't
believe that I didn't think of that as a
word to search for okay so I'll add in
that icon at some point that wasn't the
important thing I just wanted to show
you guys where I usually get my icons
and you know how to grab the code for
the SVG's I like to use SPG's because it
doesn't make a network request like for
for an image or for a font icon this you
know you just put it in line right in
your code I think the support is pretty
good among modern browsers browsers for
SVG's I've never run into a problem from
one of my users all right we've got
greetings from Vancouver and Nicaragua
so awesome
thanks for watching two snow jazz
American native we're going to get into
node and react later on maybe later this
week or in the next week so right now
we're just doing some we're just kind of
developing it out we're kind of
developing and designing kind of
together on the fly it's a little weird
weird situation just because the
timeline for when the site needs to
launch but the plan is to convert all
this into react components and render
everything sort of server-side on a
server that's running nginx a node we
run Express so nginx is going to be the
reverse proxy and expresses is going to
act as the server so we'll get into that
hopefully later this week but let's get
into some of the let me move this to the
side so we can get into some of the
JavaScript that's going to show and hide
these sections
well first we can have some CSS so I
wrote a little bit earlier and I just
commented it out to show you where's my
team page my my I'm using sass here it's
getting a little bit a little bit long
so I might have to clean this up before
the next live stream just so I can tell
where everything is okay so I'm gonna
uncomment that and when I save it I'll
show you what's going on here
so you can see now everything's hidden I
got greetings from Canada Serbia
Bulgaria Mumbai Venezuela wow you guys
are all over the place I love that
that's really cool when everybody kind
of shouts out where they're from I think
it's amazing you guys are all watching
meal probably all different different
times of the day and the different time
so any that's that's cool I'm I'm just
in a small city in Ohio and so thanks
thanks for watching
Philippines Brussels all right cool I'm
going to try to keep an eye on a live
stream but it's easy for me to get
sidetracked with the live stream and not
show anything
all right so step one is is complete
we've hidden things successfully okay
but I've added a class I'll show you the
mark-up I've added a class of open let
me you see this is getting pretty long -
I can't wait til we convert this to
react components so we can just have one
component and not have to have this huge
long page all right so we have there we
go here's a section we're looking at so
all the sections that have these these
cards for each team member or in one
container and that just gives them some
padding on the sides and keeps them
centered and I have this open class and
you can see that's what actually
displays all the rows inside that class
you can also see them I'm not hiding the
title row so the row that it actually
has the title for that section is not
getting hidden so you guys are probably
seeing this with just in case I've just
added a colon not and then in
parenthesis I add the name of the class
that I don't want this to apply to so I
wanted to apply to all rows except not
rows that have the class title row so
it's cool like I said you probably
already know that but just in case
somebody's like new to new to web
development that's what that does so
what we need to do all we need to do is
pretty simple is just move that open
class to whatever section is being
clicked on so today really just for
speed we're going to write this in
jQuery since we have to load jQuery
anyway for the framework that I'm using
the framework is materialized when we
convert this
react I'll probably do something
different with it more of the react
style way to do things like this but for
now the jQuery way will work I'm just
going to go down here to the bottom and
I'm just going to give a little comments
so I remember what this is and you guys
can if you're going to check out the
code in github you'll be able to see
that section - so in jQuery here we
start everything with that dollar sign
shortcut and let's see we want to grab
that title row that class title row and
we want to want to look for the click
function can everybody see that do I
need to increase the font let me know
why not search for this really yeah
somebody has why not search for instead
of scrolling so much that would have
been a good idea
I'll try to remember that it is getting
to the point where I need to just search
for things because getting too big okay
so we're doing this on this click
function and inside the click function
all we want to do is just add let's see
let's go with this and we want to add
the open class to the parent okay so
this section is the parent so we're
actually just going to type this which
will mean the thing that's clicked on
which in this case is going to be that
title row be careful about this in
JavaScript sometimes it doesn't mean
what you think it means
especially at least for me I found in
react when I first started using react
this did not ever mean what I thought it
was going to mean so that can be a
little bit tricky but in jQuery when you
don't click things it usually is pretty
easy to
it out what this is going to be so we're
no parent and actually it's it is just
going to be a parent we don't need to
put any the parent for this rule is
always going to be that section so now
we have that parent we're going to add
the class of open and that will show now
you may have already thought this this
is the reference to the current object
yeah you're right
somebody putting it in the lab check
this is the reference to the current
object yeah it's pretty straightforward
right now although like I said I have
run into some cases where this didn't
always mean what I thought it was going
to mean so not only do we need to open
that section actually with let's think
about this there's no reason why we
couldn't have multiple sections open so
I don't know if I want to auto close all
the other sections if we do that we
might end up with the same problem we
had on the old site and that people are
going to get stuck in the middle of a
list when they expected to be at the top
so here's what I think we're going to do
we definitely do want people to be able
to close it but I don't want it to auto
close everything else when you click one
thing so we're going to put a little if
statement and do a check we're going to
say if I don't want to do this I want to
check all right let's write this out
first
uh if the parent section is open then
we're going to then close else open okay
okay so I don't always do this but
sometimes it helps to do kind of this
just think this out logically
only somebody in the livestream
recommends you don't know J s this an
object prototypes book that's a great
recommendation that is available for
free to read maybe I'm going to write
that down I'm going to put a link to
that ok I just write that down
that's an awesome book a great resource
so you can just toggle clasp open your
right yeah I can't do toggle clasp
I always forget about toggle okay let's
just do toggle clasp so in case you're
watching this later and you can't follow
the live stream I just have a suggestion
just to use jQuery x' built-in toggle
clasp a method so let's let's change
this to toggle clasp oops okay that's
great
this should work alright let's bring in
the where we leave that at all right
let's see if this has done anything all
right it's working I have the same thing
written here hope to change this I
didn't realize that I pasted the same
title and for both of these awesome okay
now what could we do we could probably
add some sort of nicer looking effect to
that and I may do that at this point
since I'm just trying to get everything
done enough to test that we'll probably
be on the list of things to do if we
have time but it would definitely look
nicer if we had some sort of other
effect that happened when we open that
but the
basic functionality we were looking for
is there so people come to the page
they'll see this scroll down won't have
to scroll too far but then they can
click this obviously we're going to want
to add things like we want the cursor to
turn into the pointer that looks like
you're going to be able to click on it
I'm going to add our icon our plus and
minus icons and change those out but for
now we have the basic functionality and
fade 100 okay somebody is saying to use
fade 100 so actually this is a new one
to me you guys are more knowledgeable
here about jQuery than I am so this is
awesome so I'm just going to add fade
onto the end I do know about the
cursor:pointer let's see is this I'm
sure I'll know in a second whether or
not this is what you guys met and
whether it works
okay I'm not seeing that much of a
difference here maybe fade in okay it's
fade in we're slide up slide down okay
it looks like we have a bunch of options
so maybe oh um did I say that maybe I'll
have to mess with this after the live
stream and see which one I like the best
but thanks for the the only feedback
this is great where I work there's not
that many developers here and we're
usually working on separate projects so
I really enjoy whenever I have you guys
you know kind of watching me and able to
give me some feedback that's that's
awesome if you can get together with you
know fellow developers you can
definitely level up your skills so much
faster you know with help from other
people okay you're right in the live
stream they're saying try to add it add
to the milliseconds because 100
milliseconds is not really that much so
it might it might be doing something and
it's just doing it too fast for us to
and remove the toggle clasp for the
effect okay cool I'm going to try this
oh my god only have a minute left on the
live stream so I'm going to travel those
suggestions when probably later on and
can you show open the clause for
Medicare so you should the open class
okay let me show this I just had a
request to show the open class that I
did with CSS it's super basic so we can
see well first so I'm using sass instead
of straight CSS so if you're not used to
sass it might be a little bit different
but basically all I've done is these are
just nested inside so we're only doing
things with on the team page you know
the page with the ID team inside this
team card container and within the
section that says open
on every row in that section we're just
setting display to block because before
that on every row except the title rows
for all sections we've set display to
none so by default everything's going to
be set to display none unless it as this
open class on on the section does that
make sense
good jQuery show and not associative oh
man you guys are on top of jQuery I am
I've been purposely trying to do things
in just vanilla JavaScript because I'm
trying to get better at using react and
everybody that I've watched on YouTube
or read articles that said don't use
jQuery with react so unfortunately my
jQuery skills have not been getting any
better and probably been getting worse
since I've been trying not to use it so
I do appreciate all the help
all right so that's it for today thanks
for all the suggestions thanks for
watching
tomorrow tomorrow we'll have pretty much
a complete insight all the content won't
be added in yet but hopefully we can
tomorrow maybe you start doing some
testing checking all our mobile
breakpoints maybe even taking a look at
the server and how we're going to set
that up and when you can do j.crew soon
village areas yeah that's true
someone said everything you can do in
jQuery you can still do a vanilla J's
that that is true and that's the key I
found jQuery that when you're talking
especially about Dom interactions or
making like xhr you like Ajax requests
then jQuery seems like it's easier but
it is true you can do you do everything
in
in vanilla JavaScript I use jQuery right
now because I'm already loading it for
the for the framework that I'm using
okay all right cool are you welcome to
us as when people say any thanks so I'm
going to end it now I'll see you guys
tomorrow if you have any questions throw
them in the comments I read all the
comments and I'll try to get back to you
as soon as I can and you know check out
you guys have a lot of suggestions today
that's awesome so if you want to go
check out the repo and let me know what
you think if you have any suggestions
I'll tell you right now it's a little
messy just because of the speed that
I've had to develop this site with so I
apologize for the mess but pull requests
are definitely welcome or just advice in
general backronym is a variable in size
yes somebody's talking about variables
incest yeah you can definitely there's
definitely some nicer ways I could write
this for sass I'm not too worried about
it now since all these styles are going
to get broken up and add it into the
react components at some point and
they're not going to be sass at that
point so I'm not super worried about
optimizing the the sass organizing it
that much ok my channel which I think
it's just Jesse Weibull the YouTube
channel the links in the description ok
goodbye for real this time
if you have anything else just send me a
message on Twitter put it in the
comments have a great day I'll see you
tomorrow